for the last few years valrant was
heralded by some as the potential CS go
killer but all it took was a few videos
and a beta on a single map that most
people can't even get into for the
tables to completely turn
but as the hype train continues it's
left us with a very real question that
deserves a very real answer we'll CS2
kill valorent
with the Counter-Strike 2 Limited Test
in full swing and by full swing I mean
about three percent of the player base
that doesn't include me we finally have
some measured responses on how the game
feels although there are some expected
bumps and it's literally just us too the
general consensus is that the hype train
is more than Justified
come on
but as we get more news and leaks about
CS2 as well as clickbait titles from
valorent streamers it's got a lot of
people wondering what exactly Riot's
response to all this is going to be and
before all the Valor fans come for me
might I remind you that this exact
conversation happened surrounding CS go
just a few years ago and just like then
the discourse has spawned at two
separate camps those who think riots
days are numbered and those who think
otherwise ncs2 will kill battle I don't
think it will even make a dent on valo
last week well lucky for you guys I'm
here to sift through all the Hyperbole
and find out what the real answer to the
question is and honestly my conclusions
might just shock you but before we
unlock these answers we need to go back
and look at what made valent such a
successful competitor in the first place
at launch valrant flato did a lot of
things that CS go didn't or couldn't do
to start it had 128 tick servers in
standard matchmaking which is nice a
more fluid UI and a robust anti-cheat
system that although being a bit
invasive worked a hell of a lot better
than back oh and it also had consistent
content drops and somewhat regular
communication from its developer and
while even CS go diehards can admit how
nice that must be next to that balran
did a lot of things that just made it
more accessible across the board it's
cartoonish style and omission of things
like blood real guns and
terrorism made it a lot more attractive
not just broadly speaking but for
sponsors looking to attach themselves to
it hell it's been well documented that
CS go has struggled in certain countries
and at the Collegiate level for these
exact reasons baloran is also a hero
shooter which adds a level of uniqueness
that does just enough to separate itself
from Counter-Strike it also can't be
discounted that having distinct
characters improves the marketability of
your game and face it bride has
basically made their own Marvel
Cinematic Universe at this point more
than anything else valrant was a game
that was easy to pick up and play sure
in reality the game is a cluster of
abilities but actually sitting down and
playing the game with friends unstable
servers is easy CS go has always been a
bit more complicated
[Music]
yeah we can't I mean we're done that's
it that's that's a big problem with cs
it's very messy and so hard to play like
it's accessibility
[Music]
just like look at this if this was Valor
we opened up the game we invite each
other we're supposed to play look at the
that we're dealing with right now
for all these reasons valrant was able
to successfully hammerage a portion of
csgo's audience from tax shooter
veterans and streamers looking for
something fresh to disenfranchised na
Pros looking to breathe life into their
Pro careers more importantly valrant was
able to do something very very special
they brought entirely new demographics
into the tax shooter genre people who
would have otherwise never given CS go a
shot but what if I told you that Riot's
ability to do this might actually lead
to CS2 having more success in the long
run you see if you were to ask tax
shooter players which game is
fundamentally better nine times out of
ten they're going to say Counter-Strike
GO even the most staunch valoran
enjoyers will probably admit that so
here's the question what if
Counter-Strike could suddenly do all of
those things that made ballerin
successful we already know that
Counter-Strike 2 is a complete overhaul
of every aspect of the game it's quite
literally bringing the franchise into
the modern era but more importantly CS2
is solving a lot of the the issues that
CS go had better lighting subtic inputs
improved UI and if the leaks were true a
new anti-cheat system that will end
matches when a cheater is found now
knowing valve and what we can already
see from The Limited Test I don't think
they're going to budge on any of that
realism that holds the game back from
being content friendly but valve has had
over a decade of feedback and a lot of
time to study the competition they would
be stupid to not take the things from
valorent that make it more accessible
and push it even further an improved
server browser a premier matchmaking and
tournament system that doesn't involve a
third-party website hell what if
the smoke grenades isn't the only
massive gameplay change coming to the
game this guy's limit here so what is
the answer here well CS2 kill valorin if
it includes all of these things and more
honestly
probably not the same way that csgo
didn't die when Valerian came out both
these games are going to exist in Tandem
and you're allowed to like and play both
that being said I think it's foolish to
believe that Riot isn't looking at CS2
like in a weird way it's the new kid on
the Block listen I'm heavily biased I've
been playing Counter-Strike my entire
life I I get it but I honestly think
that it is the superior attack FPS
experience in almost every way and maybe
it's cope but I think a lot of people
who play CS2 as their first
Counter-Strike experience are going to
love it and never want to stop I mean
just look at the recent numbers CS go
was hitting all-time Peaks even before
the Counter-Strike 2 announcement and
every day it seems like it's breaking
new records and might I remind you that
this is basically the same game that
most people can't even play yet imagine
what happens when the game actually
releases is it going to decimate
valoran's player base absolutely not but
if I was Riot I would be already cooking
up a response when it comes to streamers
don't get it twisted sure they have
their allegiances but they're just gonna
go wherever the numbers are if their
fans want to see more CS2 they're going
to play more CS2 and vice versa could we
see reverse Exodus of valorent pros and
CS go retirees coming to see us too I
mean yeah sure anything is possible
balance franchising did Shaft a lot of
pros and if you're a player looking to
find a place CS2 could be worth the try
but that honestly all depends on if the
infrastructure will be there by the time
the game releases especially for North
America will Pros go back probably not
they left for a reason so to reiterate
is CS2 going to kill valorent no I do
not think so but just like years before
I don't think that's the right question
to begin with like I said at the jump we
already saw this exact same conversation
back in 2020 when valorant launched and
our answer then is the same as it is now
you can play both games both of them are
gonna exist everyone's gonna be fine
relax but more importantly competition
in the gaming industry breeds Innovation
so I think fans of either should be
excited about the future because valve
has been quiet for a very long time and
now that we finally have an answer it's
going to be interesting to see how both
games evolve alongside each other for
the years to come see us go survived
everything Siege war zone valorant valve
itself it is the default FPS experience
that cannot be killed but Riot finally
feeling a little bit of heat might be a
good thing for both games
CS go has always adopted will Valor do
the same
I've had no interest in playing valorant
recently I don't know why I'd have no
problems with the game really like I
think CS is better but I have no
problems with Valor and I just don't
know why I haven't played people have
been saying that the game is better than
ever and I just have zero interest no
shade towards it but that being said
let's check if we get a beta key I don't
think I'm gonna get it I don't think I'm
ever gonna get it no I'm never playing
this goddamn game never getting it